the Joe Rogan experience did you just
put it up all the mosquitoes are
carriers of yellow fever dengue fever
Japanese Emperor and sinful itis
encephalitis there's no evidence of
mosquitoes can transmit HIV studies with
HIV have shown clearly the virus
disappears the mosquito after about one
to two days yeah but what if that [ __ ]
bites you and then bites you bro look at
that last line I've never heard it
described like that the time required
for them to sceeto to digest a blood
meal Jesus Christ the only one talking
on vampires like that don't blood meal
so that means if they get someone who's
got HIV and then they get to you within
one to two days doesn't that seem like
it would get you bro that's all I'm
saying it's it's a well the Charlie
Sheen's
in your mouth Tiger blood that winning
[ __ ] don't sound - I don't believe you
do you know the difference between magic
and Charlie I don't think Charlie was
ever cool to anybody oh yeah like you
wanted we wanted to be magic at some
point in our lives everybody want to be
Magic Johnson's live show know what
fixed at those Russell Peters fix that
but Russell Peters fixed because he went
with him so what what happened was
Charlie was trying to do it by himself
and really didn't have anything to say
and people get bored after a while they
would boo him and like he was like oh
[ __ ] you I have your money and he's only
a bunch of dumb [ __ ] cuz he tried to do
this live tour but he didn't plan it out
right so then Lee did is he brought
Russell Peters with him
so Russell who's the best at work in the
crowd right he could just make something
out of nothing right
so Russell just got 10
to talk and then Russell would start
talking [ __ ] and making fun and someone
would say something Russell incorporate
that and Russell treated it like a
comedy show and turned it into something
that was actually good I am live
Russell's there so it's gonna be good
because Russell's the right Russell's
gonna handle it and turn into funny she
just did a podcast yeah yeah hi Cass
back then and nobody cared about podcast
it was apparently have some stories oh
dude oh yeah those cracked stories and
those have you willing to tell him
though oh he's tell he's already got
AIDS what's worse remember when he was
on television he was talking about just
smoking rocks yeah just all this and the
people like what yeah like what are you
saying but did that excite people in
2019 we've seen all the crackheads
no back then it was the right window of
time yeah there's like him coming
through and just being unapologetic
about doing drugs and and you don't pay
huggers to [ __ ] pay him illegally if
you kind of [ __ ] me I'm saying it was
unapologetic and that's why it resonated
and that's also why no one could get him
with a gamete to thing it's like what
are you gonna say course he'll tell you
what he did first of all no woman is
gonna say he slept at home you're sure
yeah maybe he did that to protect
himself - you just got AIDS
real quick says every time the girl
leaves the house oh by the way positive
Oh Mike you know she's just really nice
to them they like him they don't want to
[ __ ] throw him on